[Music]
kaylee joins us up next she's in madison
wisconsin hey kaley welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can ken and i help
today um so i'm just going because my
husband and i recently got into a
position where we are struggling to
pay for our firm walls so i just wanted
to kind of get some advice from you guys
oh i'm so sorry kaylee what happened
yeah um so well basically um
my i am a financial analyst um in
madison wisconsin
and i'm making 60 000 a year and i also
received a
bonus this year um my husband is a real
estate agent here and
with the healthy market it's been just
you know a little rough um
we also have three kids so um
right now we're paying like two thousand
dollars a month in child care
um so basically after all of our
expenses we have
like three hundred dollars left for
groceries
so
i've just been wondering um what we
should do to change um i have a
2019 honda pilot um with 34 000 miles on
it so
i bought it for 36 000 and i can sell it
for probably like 35.
um we also were gifted the mutual funds
last year um a hundred and six thousand
dollars so quite a bit of money
um so we have some things to fall back
on but um kaylee let me ask you
let me ask you this real quick george
george will walk you through all of this
and and but we need to find a little bit
more so
how much money is your husband making as
a real estate agent
um well it totally depends on
like the month um
you know he made like forty thousand
dollars in in a couple months and then
it was like
just offers now listen i totally
understand but i mean if you look at
last year the year before
what's what's he making what's the
average
um well we just did our 20 21 um
taxes and our taxable income was 80 000.
okay but you make 60.
um yeah after taxes like after
healthcare and
dental and um okay
what kind of debt do you guys have how
much
um well in december we just paid off all
of our debt so so you're definitely one
of our hosts our
yes
yeah we paid off our house our car and
seventy nine thousand dollars hello wow
way to go yeah we've been working really
hard but um i feel like we just like hit
a wall
well kaylee i want to just encourage you
that you guys are are not in a dire
situation i know it feels like that
because of the child care and there's
not a lot of margin in your budget but
you don't have any payments to anyone
except the mortgage right
um we paid our house off so it's
literally just like hold on you guys
have no payments in the world
even making 60k in madison there's no
money left over to eat and put food on
the table and get gas in the car um
so after
um
like my take-home pay is 3 400 a month
um and child care is 2000 a month
utilities are
about two on average uh like 250 a month
um
our car insurance maintenance gas around
214 a month
and then it's just you know fifty
dollars for my small school 75 for
internet and then
250 dollars we have our kids in some
sports right now um so it's like 300
some dollars for groceries it's like
it's pretty tight okay where's this
where's this emotion coming from what is
is it because of the stress of the
very little mark yeah
okay
yeah we just don't know when the next
paycheck's coming um on his side so
like we use our
emergency fund the last three months so
it's gone
okay
where is it going towards what's yeah
well okay so we were we had um we were
basically we were overspending um we
were spending more than my income aid
and um
like keep pulling from his his income
like his income should just be saving
but um we were pulling from it to pay
for child care and
um
anything else like we were eating out so
we're not eating out anymore i cancelled
like apple music audible like is he on
board is he on board with all this i
mean because what i'm trying to piece
together is okay so you guys walk the
baby steps out except for the fact that
you didn't really adhere to the budget
you paid off debt but but you didn't
really have a budget and so you got
yourself in trouble is that what i'm
hearing yes okay can i
yeah okay
so george i don't know if this is money
advices i i got to tell you your husband
needs to stink and put his big boy pants
on and step up and i don't know why he's
not selling houses in madison wisconsin
it's not like you're in the slums
i i i don't have the real estate data in
front of me but if he can't if the
housing market is so slow
that he can't sell houses in madison he
needs to get a better job this is an
income issue
i mean you guys need to get your budget
in place but what is he doing
well he's with the kid so we um wait a
second you're spending 2 000 a month on
child care
yeah 18 hours a week is what we can
afford um
that's with our kids um their school
they go to private school so they're in
um their tuition plus child care for our
youngest and then during the summer it's
all three of them so the monthly average
is two thousand dollars okay so here's
the deal i'm not picking on your husband
i'm not trying to be unkind do you agree
that this is an income issue with him he
can be and should be making more money
yes or no
yeah oh we both think we should well
then he needs to get busy
i'm going to give you a gift here i want
you and your husband to go watch all the
videos in financial peace university i'm
going to give you a year to ramsey plus
and i want you to get on a written
budget every month i want to know where
every single penny is going from your
income you make well above the average
household income in america and you
don't have a payment in the world
you don't have debt you don't have a
mortgage there's no excuse that you guys
can't live your life with a little bit
of margin george i gotta throw this in
here practical thing you gotta sit down
and be real about maybe pulling those
kids out of private school for a season
a season here's the four walls food
utilities housing transportation if you
get those basic needs covered yes
everything else can go away every
subscription every private school every
sport i don't care right now we've got
to get above water and we got to figure
out what the root of this is and if it's
overspending we're buckling down on this
budget because we can't live like this
you can't live with this much anxiety
you guys work too hard to be this broke